goals in this inverted pyramid of sort
of a hierarchy hi there steve kaufman
here today and i'm going to talk today
about goals goals in language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications if
you follow me on a podcast service which
i think is a good thing to do because
then you can listen especially if you're
using my videos to improve your english
you can listen to them while you're in
the car or whatever you're doing but do
leave a review i do appreciate it
so why do i want to talk about goals
personally i have the sort of
general interest in learning languages
which motivates me so i don't really
focus on any particular goals but i i
sort of gave the subject some thought
you know
so much of the time when we're learning
a language we have the feeling that
we're not progressing we're not getting
anywhere
and so i thought it is useful i kind of
looked at what i do and and what are the
goals that i focus on at different
stages in my language learning what are
what sort of is the hierarchy of goals
and so that's what i want to talk about
a bit today at least my hierarchy of
goals
what i kind of consider to be more
important at what stage in my learning
uh and
there are seven of them and i'm going to
talk about the seven today
and then i've been giving some thought
to doing
one
uh video on each of these seven goals in
other words how do we
you know achieve those goals how do we
use those goals to improve our our uh
ability in the language that we're
learning so
first of all
i see these seven goals as sort of an
inverted pyramid
uh where the first one which i will
start to discuss shortly is at the top
as a broad sort of line
and then the next one comes below it and
so they get sort of narrower and yet
they're expanding sort of horizontally
all the time
so let me tell you what i mean so the
first goal in language learning
uh the one that's easiest to sort of
measure
and which stays with you all the time
is acquiring words all right
that's why we have at link we measure
the words you know
uh we also measure phrase or we at least
let you say phrases but the key
measurement is the words you know
and
certainly that's what i focus on at the
beginning
uh
and i will get into detail when i do my
video on words
but that's kind of like the initial i
often refer to the mechanical rabbit
that you're chasing this thing to try
and you know you're running this race
and you're pursuing the rabbit to me the
mechanical rabbit is words that's the
number one goal and when you start in
the language that's what you're trying
to do you one word at a time you're
learning how this language works so
number one goal
is words acquiring words
the second goal on this inverted pyramid
one level down
is reading
reading comprehension it's a lot easier
to understand what you read
than to understand what you're listening
to so as you are acquiring words
uh you're also developing the ability to
make sense of what you read
not a hundred percent but you're
starting to make sense of what you read
if you're using link you're looking
words up you're adding these words to
your known words total or to your words
that you have looked up that are in your
database so the next sort of goal is to
increase the number of words that you
are reading something that we also
measure at link
then the third goal is listening
comprehension
it's i find it difficult to
understand what i listen to if i don't
read it so that's why in my hierarchy of
goals i start with acquiring words and i
want to see that number go up links
created you know known words
reading number of words read i want to
see that go up but at the same time i
want to work on my listening
comprehension now to some extent the
listening comprehension the learning
words the reading is all happening at
the same time but in terms of a goal
that i set for myself
initially i want that word count to go
up second of all i want to read more
words
and i'll get into more detail when i do
a video on reading the third thing is to
improve my listening comprehension
so
those are the first three goals
the next goal then and you'll you'll
sort of realize now that because i
always talk about input acquiring words
reading listening
those are the top three then come
speaking so uh as a goal
you know ultimately at the end of course
i want to be able to speak well
but
initially that's not my goal initially
my goal is comprehension words reading
comprehension listening comprehension
and if i have those a good base in those
the speaking will be easier for me and
then of course i want to speak as much
as i can but if i have that solid base
in the earlier goals the words
the reading comprehension the listening
comprehension
then the speaking is going to come now
after speaking comes
grammar or usage or speaking correctly
so
in other words i don't worry at all
about
how correctly i speak at an early stage
in the language my goals initially are
input related then i'm speaking speaking
with mistakes it doesn't matter
and then comes a point where
i want to focus in on speaking more
correctly and this comes after
struggling to speak and throwing out the
words and the phrases that i've acquired
and now i want to work
towards speaking more correctly and when
i do my video on how to learn grammar i
will talk in more detail about how we
learn grammar and speak more correctly
or
more like native speakers
so the goals so far have been
first goal biggest goal which stays with
us all of these stay with us the whole
time acquiring words
reading second goal
reading comprehension third is listening
comprehension fourth is speaking fifth
is
grammar learning to
use the language more correctly
then the sixth one is writing
and again we can start writing at any
time
but again i i just look at my own
experience i tend not to write a lot
except when i was in a situation where i
needed to write when i was learning
chinese i was on a program i was working
for the canadian government i had to
learn to read excuse me to write and to
write correctly similarly when i was a
student in france i had i had to write
correctly so there are many situations
where we need to write and write
correctly and i will do a video on how
we improve our ability to write and to
write uh you know effectively
and persuasively and accurately and all
these things so that then is the sixth
goal is the writing goal at least in my
hierarchy
and the final goal is the culture
and uh
i think
at least in my learning when i learn a
language i learn the language in order
to connect with the culture
however as a goal it's further down the
list because until i have the reading
comprehension the listing comprehension
the words
you know a better sense of the language
it's difficult to get into the details
of the culture so
again like so many of these goals we can
introduce them at any time
but i find that i'm much more interested
in
things that relate to the grammar of the
language that relate to the uh
to the culture of the language that i'm
learning if i have a better ability to
read about these things
comfortably in the language rather than
having different aspects of the culture
uh festivals or
different family relationships having
all of this explained to me say in
english
at a point where i don't have a good
understanding of the language i prefer
to save that until i can go out and
discover it for myself in the language
and so i will do another video
specifically on this seventh goal so
all i wanted to do today was to sort of
warn you let you know
that i'm going to be doing these seven
videos
on the seven goals
uh at least in so far as my learning is
concerned
which are these
goals in this inverted pyramid of sort
of a hierarchy of goals
the top one is
words
get getting as many words as you can the
second one is developing your uh reading
comprehension the
second one the third one is developing
your listing comprehension the fourth
one
is speaking
the fifth one is working on your
correct usage
the sixth one is writing and the seventh
and final one is
really gaining an appreciation of the
culture
so there you have it of course there's a
lot of overlap and many of these things
it can be happening at different stages
but that is my hierarchy of goals so i
hope that was useful thank you for
listening bye for now